welcome to this video
this will be about the second round of
tata's gear 2013
and um
as yesterday's video for round one
had some good feedback
regarding the format that i covered all
games
quickly
i'll keep it
this way for now unless we i get some
really outstanding game that i think
merits um deeper coverage
so i'll go through our games quickly
relatively quickly we had a one hour
video yesterday and i
expect something similar with this one
so um let's start
i'll start with um
with what game let's start with the wang
hao against um peter lecko
and um we get a
queens indian defense wang hao plays um
mostly d4 but he's also an e4 player we
have here
a d4 opening and leko has long abandoned
the grundfault and switched to
nimzo queens indian
structures
and
in fact we have
this popular variation with g3 and
bishop a6
here unfortunately wang hao played a b3
it's not a bad move but it is the most
yeah
solid move probably together with queen
a4
here's a very exciting gambit line with
queen c2
c5 d5
and um
black wins the pawn on d5
which can lead to very tactical play but
unfortunately he um
didn't go for that um i also think this
is probably um
diffused by now and not so dangerous for
black but
just um
judging from the frequency with with
with um white playing b3 nowadays
maybe queens two isn't so dangerous
anymore so we got um
this check on before to
oops to misplace the d2 bishop not the
queen the bishop
the bishop rather would be on b2 so this
check is useful for black
and now
black sets up this typical
pawn wall in the center to oppose this
bishop
so c65 to
make the g2 bishop um
passive for the moment
and we continue
with pretty much normal moves here white
has
yeah
rather
wide choice of plans
he couldn't try for e4
with the move knight c3 which
incidentally would
let c4 hang but it's still interesting
he went for a form which is
also an interesting plan in this
position
trying to push a5 and make this bishop
look bad
a5 this was the idea
and now like i needed to
capture on b6 with the queen as we see
we have this um
pawns in the center and the huge
tension here with all those capturing
possibilities
and the main feature is also this setup
so white
goes
off this c file
of course the huge danger
of this kind of setup is that simply
everything gets traded down
and we see that in the game
we had
lots of exchanges in the center
and um
yeah what's um what's left
this pawn on c4 it's safely blockaded
and the only slight issue that black has
he's got
the somewhat weirdly placed queen
but we see that um
black manages to simplify further and
here he doesn't have anything to fear
rook c7 keeps everything protected
and now this um basically fizzles out to
a draw without
much happening
yeah blackheads has this counterplay on
d3
and
he even temporarily wins a pawn
but
it's uh it's a pin
and this
at the end leads to
repetition
black cannot really do anything against
this let's say rook d1 and if he tries
to to keep the knight let's say he goes
here
then
this will uh will lead to trouble
where do you go now this knight doesn't
have a square if you
protect this passively then
okay 2 simply wins the knight it doesn't
have any squares
everything's nicely covered
so black cannot really play for win and
after rook
d1 night before it was um
yeah in this
pendulum over and over again so i would
draw him yeah pretty uneventful game
but this is rather typical sometimes of
those queens indian catalan setups
where um
this huge tension is built up in the
center and everything gets traded down
if both players play
in a um an exact manner
okay so
next game
is me against the kayaking
we have
also
queens indian start but we transpose
into a to a nimzo setup
and black plays d5 here this is
interesting
this way we transpose
to the first round game
off
let me think
this was soccer love against um
sokolov against
well how i'm trying to remember this i
knew zokolov was was white and i think
it was against
wang hao
i'm not 100 sure really
maybe um
let me look this up quickly
this almost
guess it was circular one how
and in this game
zukov played the immediate a7 his
recommendation
from the book but here we get the the
old
continuation very
well known back from the 70s
the only thing which was really
irritating was black played queen e7
which looks rather normal to
prepare knight d7 and
connecting the rooks also possible
knight e4
is prepared d5 is hanging for the moment
so it's not
possible next move or something but it's
the general idea to plant the knight on
e4
what was really curious was now white
played b5
and here black can play all kinds of
moves mostly taking
but here he played the very weird move
queen back to d8 which is a novelty
not uh not much of a surprise that's
move is new it looks very weird
just putting the queen back on d8
the idea is after taking on b5 that you
get
this square back for the bishop on e7
and this is actually what happened
so black secures his bishop
it it seems playable it's only very
weird to to undevelop the queen
in the game we get um
sort of a standard structure
where white always is a little bit
better
but it's um not much really
those pawns look weak but
black has some possibilities to go for
c5
and
get some dynamism going
and yeah white
doesn't have such an
yeah such an easy way to to progress
here
an idea would be the move e4 to prepare
this
to
also get to the c6 weakness
but it's also not so easy to to get this
going knight e4 as mentioned as an idea
we see a5 and c5 and um
yeah in this position actually a6 c4 in
this position
white has a very weird move as it um at
its support disposal
which is really a kind of a computer
move
he played
queen
b5 which is the human move i would say
covering the a6 pawn
the computer
suggests this this strange move
with the following consequences knight
takes cannot take with the king of
course
then you have this check
and then white will take next move on b7
and has an extra pawn with a great
position
so
this is not
possible but
oops sorry
tapes but knight takes and what now
now white just plays queen b5
and it's similar to the game but white
has just sacrificed this bishop
beforehand
now um if black would secure the bishop
with bishop c8
there's knight d5 coming
and after queen d6
knight b4 we have a very strange
position
where um
yeah white has a couple of pawns
for his um for his piece he's got two
pawns
this is weak though and
he's got this very strong pawn on a6
um very interesting position and very
hard to assess
the computer likes it for white but um
i'm not so sure it's um
it's certainly tricky
it's no wonder that white didn't play
that he just played queen b5
especially since
this continuation
he also
could have taken
here instantly
but queen a3 is a bit of a bit of an
annoyance with knight e4 and rook c8
coming
and black gets counter play
but look at the structure white
was certainly hoping that
those two pawns which are weakness
both pawns are
might give him a little bit to play for
but black is just too active he's got
the c file
and this is really the point
knight e4 is an active move
trying to
use the temporary um
yeah the
activity that black is having at the
moment trying to
take use of this
and it still looks like like a little
bit of something
but um like
the whole game um plays a very active
and good defense
we see um
exactly this black sacrifices the b6
pawn
and goes for activity against those
points
it's very difficult for for whites to
to keep his
check yeah to keep his pawns
black is very active if white would he
played this move
white would take now here
black gets this back and has two pawns
attacked and this is um
no good at all
note that white's pieces are off on the
queen side and black has got this this
counter play going
maybe there was some more exact way to
to go for white but i believe that this
should be enough for a draw as black is
so active and as mentioned those pieces
don't really play
and check
it
check fizzled out to nothing really
yeah rook f2 and
we exchange exchange even more
and it's not much happening at all
um okay those uh games weren't
so exciting admittedly
um let's go now for caruana against hari
krishna
hi krishna winner of round one against
giri so
it's curious to see how he
fares with the black pieces against
karana and karana place e4
and we got the berlin defense
of the spanish
this was to be expected hari krishna is
an expert on this
on this opening
so caruana pretty much could expect to
get this position when he went 1e4
and what has he prepared against the
balloon
you have this slow d3 move
which nowadays
um yeah it's probably
close to becoming the main line because
um
white is simply tired to play this end
game the ball in more land game
okay bishop c5 the most active
way to play for black you could also
play with g6 and bishop e7
but bishop c5 is the most active move
c3 castles
castles
and d6 black now protects the pawn
white the move before could take the
pawn but it's rather risky
okay so what do we have here
yeah the typical
slow
rulo pass spanish opening with c3 and d3
where the whole
game
yeah
flows in a very very slow manner
it's kind of a maneuvering game
and
in this game however white relatively
quickly
took on c6 to
to my at least um slight surprise
usually um white still tries to keep
this bishop
on the board and um
yeah play with more pieces simply
to keep the position more complicated
black certainly has good chances to to
equalize here
if you compare this black is um
setting up his pieces in exactly the
same manner as in the in the italian
game the juco piano
but white has got bishop b5 a4
instead of bishop c4 to b3 which is the
usual way to go in the juco piano where
black already equalizes rather
comfortably and
here white lost time with the bishop so
it cannot be really much
okay but um caruana took on c6
and um continued in this way
yeah if you look at this kind of
position for white you you know
that um
the berlin defense is really a real
headache for white uh white players if
you aim for this kind of position it
must be a sorry state in the other lines
as white um certainly
doesn't have much
to
put it mildly
yeah black guy even goes for d5
activating in the center you could have
also played slow moves of course
bishop e3 bishop f8
yeah and this is
curious now
knight 3 to d2 and now black played the
really weird looking move knight to h5
and at first i couldn't really
figure out what the idea of this move is
and it's a it's
frankly it's a very simple idea
black simply wants to play d4 and win
this bishop
it doesn't have a square
knight h5 just took the g5 square under
control so if white would play a nothing
move let's say a3
black goes d4 attacks the bishop and it
has nowhere to go
so knight h5
yeah just poses a very crude threat here
and
the fun thing is
white's reaction was um oops it was h3
um attacking this bishop
and what what did black play now i think
this is really funny
black um simply took on h3
because this idea is still uh
valid after after capturing d4 black got
the piece back
but
he sacrificed on h3 to prevent this
capture on g4 which would have attacked
the knight this is why he couldn't play
d4 immediately
maybe i put it on the board quickly d4
white could take um
here
and here
and he's got an extra extra pawn at the
end
with a clearly better position so this
is why he
he just took
and then played d4 to win this bishop
really funny
okay
like got the piece back
and now we have um
a rather
unconventional position white has got
this pawns in the center which
control
quite a good number of squares it's not
necessarily clear that
those pawns are weak i don't think
they're really weak at all
um as they fulfill important functions
but the white has a bit of an airy king
side
but on the other hand has potential
ideas on the g file i think this is
about equal
it's a
dynamic
quality though it's not like a draw or
something
some quite quite an interesting fighting
position
yeah black intensifies the pressure on
d3
the whiter needs to advance to keep the
spawn
yeah intending to activate the bishop
and white
decides to exchange the knight
yeah the king looks a bit bit silly on
g3 but it's no not in real danger
yeah c5 um
surprised me a bit but you will see the
idea soon black wanted to provoke this
move
to
go here
and open up the position at the end
yeah this
position um to be honest looks to be to
me at least um
looks uh good for black but um it's it's
not easy at all
to um
to show something concrete right now
covered this
if he would have taken on f5
then there's the strong move e4
and this knight
doesn't really know where to go
it only has this square and this looks
rather
rather sorry after taking here
black is
yeah clearly better here
this is why he
covered and now black intends to play f4
maybe um around here he had something
better it's really
clear that black is in the driver's seat
but
it's um not
not very evident how to how to improve
at least
um when i did my quick very quick
analysis um before starting the video i
didn't see anything together with the
engine
yeah it looks nice this uh
the setup but how do you really make
progress
in the game
white um try to get some some counter
play going
and
black decided to take it off
and this is probably now
just around equal there's not much not
much going on maybe there was something
for black but it wasn't uh
totally easy and this this still looks
looks good i mean
but um probably it's it's nothing
serious
lex king isn't exactly safe
also
yeah look at
these kind of ideas
with um with lots of checks coming and
we are close to a draw i think
they
played a couple of checks and
check
check check
yeah it's this kind of position where
both kings are so open against the
queens that
some sort of perpetual will end the game
it's only
a question which side
will give this perpetual
and here
black
like was the
the side with the with all the checks
so um
a good fight but uh still a draw at the
end maybe black had something somewhere
but
it wasn't like the computer um was just
giving win after win end it was easy to
to improve
it's um
just um an optically good position for
black but hard to tell how he could
could win possibly
okay so now let's go to um to the real
star game of the round
at least on paper ronin against carlton
the two
top seats in the tournament naturally as
carson is work number one and aronian is
world number three just a couple of
points short of kromnic who overtook him
the lightest
latest list
so um
what opening do we do we get
a gruenfeld probably
no carson actually goes for the king's
indian
and this opening he he really plays um
very rarely but um
he plays any opening it seems so
we have
this h3 line which aronian already
played in the first round
and um
interestingly
magnus now go with knight c6
and i happen to play this um h3 line
myself and
knight c6 um i always regard it as um
yeah to be honest um just a nonsense
move
i'm not not quite sure what to make of
this
let's see what happens white just played
d5
and now carson played knight to b4
and
yeah still i'm not impressed i'm i'm not
quite sure what
what the idea of uh of all this uh this
is
um black loses time with this knight and
uh he probably has to move it again and
um
it's not clear that um
the moves that white is making in the
meantime are useless um not at all
like bishop b2 e6
yeah attacking the center maybe a rookie
eight
also coming and we have this move
knight d2 yeah this was important
if
white would play a move like castles
then
there is
this possibility white cannot take with
the c pawn se4 was hanging
like this
and um
therefore you would need to take here
and then black setup
makes a little bit of sense at least
can try to
relocate the knight and this
this piece
is nicely positioned on the e file
this is why white played knight d2 to
allow a recapture with the c pawn if
black would take
he played a5 though to at least support
this this knight when it goes back to a6
yeah b6
sort of improving the the structure it
seems
but um
i still
don't see why this isn't simply a bad
position for black
white has a space advantage a3 b4 coming
and um i'm pretty sure that um
aronian was happy with his position but
carson wasn't
it's um
pretty clear i think yeah king h8 this
uh
prepares
knight g8 we see um in the game
what uh what the point of this
a3 it was kicked back
and queen c2
white is preparing further action on the
queen side
and now black actually closed the
position
um yeah
probably
in order to get at least a bit of play
you need to play e5 and f5 later
the problem is in the long run white
will play rook b1 and b4
rook b1 knight g8 b4 and this would have
happened also if black wouldn't have
played e5
and this is the whole problem of black
setup
this really stranded knight on a6 this
knight is just a terrible piece
white has the space advantage on the
queen side and he's got um
quite a number of ideas to break through
here connected with c5 or with the move
knight to b5
we see that in the game after f5
aaronian played the interesting move
knight b5
um around here i think there's some
also maybe room for improvement white
has
quite a good choice of of lines this was
a tempting move though and it's in fact
um a p sacrifice if you look at this
black could play f4 here
and what would white uh answer this
bishop doesn't have a square but he's
got the very strong move bishop takes b6
sacrificing the bishop
yeah and this leads to
complete disaster for black
the mate threat on f7 so black needs to
cover the the square on f7
and then c5 and the combination of this
pawn duo knight c4
and this terrible piece on a6
i think this is close to winning for
white
black has absolutely no counter play and
those
pawns um they'll probably decide the
game in the center and on the queen side
so f4 was i think a big mistake
so carlton avoided that and he played
bishop to h6 which was
another point of this
g8
maneuver with the knights to prepare
bishop to h6
but um we see that after taking
taking on f5
and f4 which is the typical maneuver
black's king
has got some
problems with this cover
the bishop on g7 is often a problem
piece in the king's indian it is
structurally the the bad bishop
but it's also the bishop that covers the
king and if the bishops are exchanged
and white opens up with f4
then the king on g7 can feel um
yeah a drought of um
defenders
and still black has got
this uh this miserable piece on a6
i think white is um much better in this
position
this is also confirmed
by the computer of course
but um
when i looked at this um i never
together with the engine managed to get
something
really big going from white i think it's
it's quite amazing
carlson somehow manages to
keep this um position um yeah
yeah he keeps the hold it he holds it
together in a way
that white doesn't have a simple win at
least
um
i didn't see any and uh of the engine
also didn't
it really looks terribly shaky for black
but um
just look at this i mean you've got an
a6 knight an h6 knight
the bad king it looks terrible but
how does how does white win really
check
this doesn't look too bad if you ask me
but um
maybe it's um it's simply not enough but
yeah there has to be something but
i didn't um
didn't have the time to
to look at this very deeply it looks
really bad for black but
how to how to punish him
check this is what uh aronian came up
with check
which is not bad i mean white still is
better
what is this knight doing
but
maybe it
it's just just enough counter play
the knight is at least attacking the
spawn
and
therefore the rooker needs to cover it
again you would think that 96 um
is great for white but he simply ignores
this the knight a6 um
covers
cover c7
yeah
it's um
it's it's better for white all the time
but
somehow um
maybe it's it's not a win
i don't know
here g4 was played i just um
i was thinking about b5 what about
b5 um okay so what if i take here
king chick
hmm
hmm yeah this looks uh rather good for
white
you can on king before you can
try to break through here
this
is too quick
too quick really
b5 maybe b5 here
of course we are um
we are down
there's not much time left but ronin
still had 20 minutes on his clock he
didn't have a huge time pressure
hmm this is this is curious
g4 is not a bad move don't get me wrong
but this looks good with the idea of
rook takes an f5
is black able to play something else i'm
not sure
yeah maybe this was the point where
where white could could cash in on on
his advantage
yeah he played g4 as mentioned
and now like um
yeah it's still worse but
maybe it did solid
oops now this was too much
yeah white played knight f4 and now try
to use the the g pawn
and c6 now we see that um black is
successful in
liquidating more and more pawns
yeah and now
it's um it's over i think in terms of
an advantage
d5 is just hanging
and this is
the last the last try threatening rook
h6 checkmate
but black has the funny moves hooked to
e3
and here they agreed to draw
because this rook sacrifice
just
clarifies the position
and black gets the last pawn
with the draw
yeah maybe a somewhat lucky escape for
for carlsen i mean this b5 move looks
looks really strong in this position
and the whole kind of
setup that that he played was very
dubious i mean
this is the kind of ideal
picture for white and a king's indian
where
this uh knight on oops i keep making
this mistake
where this a6 knight is is stranded and
often a victim for white's
play on um
on the queen side only when he opened to
the king side and weakened his king
white's attention shifted to this side
and
it was a very shaky very shaky game for
black
okay so next one um
is
what let's let's let's do giri against
uh anand
giri playing e4 usually he plays d4 this
main move
but he
tries to
vary a bit with e4 now and then
and
yeah
plays
various openings against e4 but the
classical yeah the normal
spanish the rui is one of the
one of the lions
yeah and he's actually offering a
martial gambit here
which is
which is declined
with the d3
one of the
numerous um end time
martial systems
black plays just d6 and now a3 this is
um an alternative to c3 which is also
played of course
here black has um
a number of options you can play knight
a5
similar to the chigorin line or you can
play one anon plate knight to b8
this um
maneuver
stemming from the hungarian player julia
breyer from the
1920 or 30s when he invented this
this um has the idea to improve the
knight
and to make the c-pawn
mobile later
okay let's um
see what happens black managed to
exchange the
dangerous um
roy bishop
and um
frankly speaking there's not much going
on i mean
look at this this is
again one of those
slow
reload setups
where
white cannot really count on much
the problem is you play e4 and one of
those lines like the marshall or the
berlin in the
example before
is
analyzed so much and very much okay for
black that very often the white players
try to
play those slow setups to get them
to get a longer
game with more pieces on the board but
it
can also easily fizzle out to nothing
we see what what happens a4 queen to b6
or very very standard
yeah and we also see um the clock times
we have 20 moves played
and arnold has um spent about um
30 minutes for this he didn't
think long and gary has spent a little
bit more time but
let's see what happens now he invested
10 minutes for rookie 3
and anand played very quickly queen to
d8 which makes sense he only wanted to
get the rook over to the b file to
initiate play there and now very
very interesting
um giri came up with the amazing move
knight to f5
this was obviously the the idea
um of rookie 3 but still it can come
as quite of a shock if you
didn't really expect the move
yeah it's really playable like um
i mean he can take the knight but it's
very very risky
arnold actually played
b form but let's check
the capture white would simply retake
and
attack this knight
so um where should it go let's say to g7
and then
white has the move
rook to g3 and now it gets really really
dangerous what is black supposed to do
now
there are threats of
discoveries and also taking on g7 and
then
um move the knight
if black plays for example king to h8
just just a
sample line then 95 wins on the spot
threatening this
end knight f7
so you cannot really evacuate the king
and if you would
cover g7 then white has the move queen
to f3
threatening f6
and this is also
quite dangerous for black
i don't think he really should
should take the piece
and uh not after some consideration
like 20 minutes
it's cool to see the clock times here
played
before they are sometimes not 100
percent accurate but it
it's close
okay before just ignoring all this and
this is probably the best uh
way to go
i played the rook to g3
of course now black cannot take it all
but uh
he doesn't need to can play
just um
normal moves ignoring all this and try
to play on the b farm in fact
if you look at this
i wouldn't be surprised if um
some in-depth analysis would
prove that black is better here because
those pieces they look aggressive but
they are very very far away from the
queen side and if you are not able to
deliver mate here or
get something very serious going then
those pieces easily can be misplaced how
would the rook ever come back to the
queen side i mean
this position without queens
of course um if you just take the queens
off then knight takes e7 would be
possible but yeah just imagine the
queens were offering an end game then
black is probably just winning because
the rook on g4 is such a ridiculous
piece
but in the game it seems that
white has enough activity
yeah the queen is nicely placed on d5
and
he managed to to win this pawn on a6 but
it's just a temporary
the idea was that
black gets to exchange queens now
and this is what what i was talking
about now the rook on g3 is quite a
silly piece
but dwight um was very quick and
activating it
check
see
he um instantly brought it back into
play and even um
gave away a pawn to do so
but um in the meantime
this g4 g5
is a really good setup
an active one
keeping this bishop bad
and a position with
white entering on the seventh and um
attacking
those pawns is probably just okay for
for white we see what happens
white um
even can't afford to exchange rooks and
even
here um arnold himself offered to draw
despite being a pawn up but it's it's
really a simple draw
king takes
and now white just threatens king e4
getting
the pawns back he needs to play f5 black
check takes takes
takes
and here
why does the pawn down but there's
simply
no way for black to make any progress
it's um just this let's say the extra
pawn is the e5 pawn and if this would be
on the board it would simply make no
difference at all
why it simply does nothing and stays
black cannot
make any any kind of progress
so um yet another draw it was
interesting though with knight f5
but i think um
rishi was was correct and not taking
taking the knight and maybe had some
chances for an advantage but
it wasn't entirely clear probably
okay so now we have two games left and
both the
games um
would um
yeah you could could do really long
videos on because they are long they're
complicated
but okay i decided on this quick format
um we have the first game nakamura
against sokolov
nakamura playing c4
and zukolov plays e5
he's a very classical player
using um
tried and tested
opening systems
with uh central play piece play
so it's quite a logical choice and
nakamura plays some some offbeat
on line against this i believe at least
this concrete move order is quite
quite unusual okay i think this is this
is a
known line but quite quickly we get a
position which is really weird with f3
and
i'm not quite sure i mean i think um the
castles on knight e3 would be would be
normal
the way he's he's playing um i simply i
simply think that
black is is better
very quickly
bishop h3 probably wants to prevent but
look at this position black has
um
quickly
been able to exchange the strong bishop
and now he
okay knight f5 okay need to of course
protect the queen but black simply has
good pieces yeah all pieces are fine
and um
keeping pressure on the center
and white simply has pawn weaknesses
here you cannot move any of this the
knight is placed in front of the pawns
which is
yeah according to classical principles
not the greatest way to play but
it's um
sometimes okay
but all in all all blacks pieces play
and white's pieces
don't really do much
i mean this just looks looks bad
he decided to
unbalance with
an exchange sacrifice on f6
but
still black is certainly uh much better
here
yeah here um zukulov played played in an
interesting way he didn't need to do
this but
he played knight e7 and the idea is to
exchange white's most active and only
active piece on e3
this is even worth a pawn in his book
now the knight gets exchanged
white played c4 now
if white would would take here then
there's roughly two
and
the knight can be captured this way in
fact
um this is even a force made already
have a look at something like this
check and made in a couple of moves
so this leads to
after a couple of
moves
to this ugly structure
black still um just an exchange up
and it's really hard to believe that um
that white would probably hold this
position
but see what happens it gets um becomes
a real fight now
yeah black decides to
get off the queens his the king wasn't
so secure
and okay this end game
yeah should be willing for black but
it's um
still some work to do
yeah white couldn't
avoid the exchange
and this is um
let's just continue a couple of moves
it simply looks like an easy technical
win
but
maybe it
wasn't wasn't so easy at least
it gets tricky it gets tricky
yeah this is um
probably the right idea
not not sure if um
this was the best way to to to play this
the idea is of course f4 if white would
take here
then rook takes a3 is very simple the a
pawn promotes
so white needs to take here
and then black captures on h4
and gets the h1 he gets a passport
finally the only issue is of course
those pawns
white has some counter play with
advancing the pawns
and
to be honest you could um
analyze this for ages it's
um it's advanced
h4
in this position um
if you look at this with the computer it
all looks very clear-cut
the computer says okay
rook g3 and gives a plus six or
something
if you continue this line
it leads to
a winner of those pawns and this is of
course
very easy but the critical line is that
black
first gets the rook to f3
sort of freezing the pawns and then he
advances uh with the pawn or comes over
with the king
um this looks very easy in retrospect
but um
to to see what kind of difficulties
black faced after h4
wasn't so so easy at all
believe me zokolov is not bad at
calculating it is certainly not a bad
endgame player
this probably also wins but it gets a
bit more more tricky
now white um
keeps the pawns
check
yeah this looks very weird i know
but uh let's say black would play um
this move
looks good right
but after this unfortunately black needs
to resign
you cannot uh go like this but h2 this
was
i guess um what was planned
but
the the problem is after f7
there's this counter threat
getting a queen and black has nothing
better to take here
take here
and uh it's questionable if this is a
this is a win
we see in the game
that um
some check shuffling
we get exactly this
check
and
this position
you can analyze for a long time and it's
very very tricky
the
issue is if black would get the pawn
i think this position is winning
even this is not trivial at all
if you are a member of iccm
grandmaster yamalinsky did a video
series on this end game
exactly
the end game without the e pawn if you
put the e pawn on the board just
this bishop
just these those pieces without the pawn
and this is um
winning for black in most cases um and
even this isn't easy at all now white
has the e pawn
i just went through this quickly with um
with the engine it seems that black
could win at some point
but um
as it turned out in the game check
i go through this really quickly it's uh
check
yeah for example here
the computer wants to go
rook e1 and actually um
it seems that this wins the e pawn but
i can i can give you the computer line
just for
just for argument's sake
check
and here it seems that after this
this
it's one
king h4 is checkmate
if the bishop
moves
along this diagonal it's a check and
this is gone
yeah this is one and d5 gets lost with
the lost position
yeah
yeah something like this but um it's
it's tricky
zokolop was down to five minutes
and um he tried something else
check
and
white managed to
get the pawn to e7 and this probably is
a draw
as uh the bishop on this diagonal always
keeps both pawns covered but um don't um
yeah i wouldn't bet uh
that uh
something uh dear to my heart on this
it's um it's very difficult to to
analyze this position
with limited time
after a couple of more moves
here jaw was agreed
and yeah
nakamura really had to defend from move
like 15 or something
in this position and
hold the jaw probably uh zokolov
was winning at more than one point in
the game but it
wasn't
so trivial at least from my point of
view
for for a top-class player
he certainly would be quite angry with
himself
okay and now um let's go for the last
game
of this video this is vanveli against
huifon
and
yeah vanveli surprisingly plays one e4
he very rarely does that he's a d4
player
um yeah
all his life
if i remember correctly
but he surprised with the king's indian
already in the first first round
so uh he's got some
tricky things up his sleeve yeah who you
found um goes to the sicilian now not
not the french
she lost with the french the round
before
and um fun really plays knight c3 so
interesting preparation
g6
yeah this this isn't isn't orphan played
actually
but probably uh not so bad i think the
argument against this move
is g form
but um okay it doesn't happen
while it simply transposes to an open
sicilian we we get then get the dragon
and this is um a modern way to play this
as black
the sharpest continuations
of course are
connected with
long castling and h4 move like
moves like these
but
when valley plays it in a more solid
fashion he plays
a4 and
we get this
yeah this look doesn't look so
troublesome for black at first sight but
um yeah she needs to be cautious
the a pawn is a potential
weakness and
white is pretty well coordinated
against this pawn
just a couple of moves later
white already looks rather good i think
with the pressure on the a pawn and
black gun doesn't have
half much really to
to go um
in terms of active play
a6
yeah this is a good
regrouping check
the knight is nicely positioned on e3 it
still has this knight d5 idea
but
it covers c2
so white is quite ammonia cm
queen b5
yeah g4 very aggressive um probably also
good
white has a very secure position in the
center and on the queen side and
this just
puts more pressure on black
and
here you only have two choices you need
to allow g5 by wide
and then possible oops
possible 95 at the later stage when the
knight doesn't control the the square
or you must play
this move
which is also um
not
really a welcoming
decision if you look at this d5 is now
really really weak
and d6 also so it was um a choice
between two
yeah two
unwelcoming prospects
the
let's look at this just for comparison's
sake
and white would would it want cm
it doesn't doesn't look very attractive
also
okay she played e5
queen back
yeah building up
the spin so white steps out of this
rook c8
queen e2 yeah all very logical
um here i think
white had a very good alternative
or i think is always meant as
my observations together with with the
computer
um yeah b4 was was good probably
just intending b5 using
those
pieces on the a file
and um
black doesn't really have a good
response
how to how to prevent this it's simply
not possible
black would play something like this b5
rook moves and then i just take on a6
and it's simply a pawn
not
not much else to say
pawn is upon
yet b4 was very strong but but white
keeps them a pretty big advantage anyway
the way he played it um
wasn't bad at all
keep in mind that they both were on
about five minutes
and eight moves until the time control
so you um
usually not too bad off
if you just
sort of keep the position and keep the
advantage
and think about some concrete measures
later
you sometimes miss things this way but
it's a
rather practical way to play
yeah white still has an excellent
position
for example he played queen e1 now
you always could think about the knight
c4
this this is an option but simply the
pressure on d6 is strong
okay but what you played it wasn't
wasn't bad at all
yeah
utmost pressure on the default
yeah this is um an example of
this famous uh
setup um
i struggle again alohan
or alakine's gunned
with the rooks in front of the queen
yeah black is simply very passive
here again knight c4 was was a good move
hard to see how black
would even keep the d6 pawn it's
probably not possible
yeah why it still retains a big
advantage
but knight c4 i think was was stronger
the fun thing is
that after rook a1 here
white had
multiple
possibilities but rook a1
was a rather unlucky move
and
we found that a really good job now to
exploit this she played 97
intending knight to c5 and the problem
is
um yeah
what does white do with the with the b
pawn
especially after rook a1
he's in he's in a fork if black manages
to to capture on b3
if white would take d6
you need to look at this
then black can just take
and take here
and it gets really really shaky
something like this check
and black guy is probably winning the
game
so white cannot take on d6 and what is
what is he doing now
you've got knight c5 and he also got
knight
c5
these kind of ideas
in addition to the b3 weakness yeah at
the end he came up with rookie one
knight c5
rook d6
yeah and this position believe it or not
is already
very close to win for black
got knight e6 d4 knight e6 f4 and
most important you've got the a pawn
white needed to play something else
before
probably in this position
something like knight to d5
with with this idea check
check
of course i just didn't see this as a
line
very complicated stuff
probably a draw would have been the
correct result but as it went in the
game
black had a huge advantage
here there are multiple threats one
simple threat is to take on e4 so let's
say white he went here
but let's say white would play move like
h5
then black simply takes here
check
check and wins the house
it's already next to pawn and all those
pawns
get lost with check
so white needs to retreat the knight
probably
and tm
rook b2
looking at this
sensitive square
threatening 94 again
so repetition
but now a4 black simply pushes the a
pawn
and what is white's counter play
there really is no no counter play the
problem is white cannot move much
if you would move the rook let's say
here
there's simply this move you're pinned
along the third rank
and you simply cannot move um
your pieces it's really a sorry um sorry
state of white's position he tried
counter play with the h pawn
knight d3
in fact um here
a3m or g5
g5 probably was the strongest but
okay 93 it's not not bad
why took wookie3
here
white um
also had this move
but black can play a3
it's a very complicated black is better
but it's not not 100 clear
he played rook e3 and in fact now
now black um could um could play
a3 she what she did
c5
of course the simple line was rook takes
rook takes queen takes
a3 and the pawn promotes
and very though played c5 which is
much much trickier
black
black just just took this
but
what about a2 now
isn't this just winning
she didn't play that
but um isn't this winning
let's uh let's have a look c6
and this is the the cool point about
this
black now promotes
white plays this move and
believe it or not
this is a draw
black has a complete
extra queen here and it's a draw
because
the knight is um yeah the king's best
friend
an old saying
which
is certainly true the knight
defends the king admirably
there is no check even
for black with two queens
and white is threatening a queen e7
with a perpetual
if um
black would play something like this
then queen d7
check and this even mates
so um
black cam simply
has no way to avoid the draw
something like this is from the
mentioned perpetual check
so my guess is that who you found in
this position
um calculated this of course
and she saw that this is a draw but now
comes
the the big point
a2 c6
here instead of queening which is this
draw after c7 black can play queen f7
and now white has no way to prevent a1
queen
and this in fact is completely winning
she didn't see this but um with two
minutes on the clock
no way to to blame a human being for not
for not seeing this so she just instead
took off the pawn
exchange
knight h4 and now
white gets the counter player on g6 and
in fact
this is a draw check
check
check and we have a perpetual
just before white is um
giving the perpetual
so um
yet to sum it up um yeah black was
thoroughly outplayed here and then when
really
really um stumbled with
starting with c4
c4 still keeps advantage no no doubt
about it
but
when black was able to get in this 97 c5
maneuver
the the
the pendulum swung
to um
swung whatever
black was better and uh
she really should have won the game
probably at the end but
it was uh too difficult with uh so
little time on the clock
so a draw at the end
after um yeah both sides
missed chances
so um yeah
all seven games and we have seven draws
but i don't think um
it was um
uninteresting chess i mean
people often complain about draws but
the problem is not the draw the problem
is
the the quick draw the uneventful draw
here we really had fights and um
some games really should have been
decisive like
zukulov's game or this game maybe
aronian's game also against carlson
yeah i hope you enjoyed the video
it's been quite long but you
gotta look at all the games and
hope um took something out of it
yeah thanks and probably
i'll post round three tomorrow cheers